i am a survivor of
a domestic violence relationship and
not at any point was david and i in an
abusive
relationship tamar braxton is speaking
out
after an abuse allegation was leveled
against her
i loved david he was my best friend
on wednesday the 43 year old tv
personality appeared on tamrin hall
and denied her ex david a adephyso's
claim that
she attacked him david filed for a
domestic violence restraining order
against tamar in september
e.t has reached out to david for comment
a few days after david's filing
during an instagram live he claimed
tamar assaulted him when he was driving
at a high speed with an unexpected blow
to his neck
i will never never bring myself to
attack
tamar somebody i've spent so long with i
never will
it's just not something i will do i'll
speak the truth
here's the truth i've been a victim
of domestic violence domestic assault
i uh i was attacked
he went on to claim that she was also
secretly recording him
while tamar denies all that claiming
that she
voice recorded the alleged altercation
while david was the one to film it
i voice recorded it he videotaped it
he has a camera in his car he has the
videotape
he has it was in his car release it
david also claimed that the alleged
incident led him to crash
his rolls-royce causing 30 thousand
dollars in damages
the 49-year-old added that the alleged
altercation was his
basis for filing a restraining order
he was an amazing amazing partner
he was my son's best friend as well they
were best friends
and it's just so hard because
through everything else i never expected
this from him now i have to be real with
myself
was is he acting like this because he
found me the way that he
found me probably i don't know
of course all this comes after the
reality star
credited david with saving her life in
an emotional instagram post in august
after he found her unresponsive in july
at the ritz-carlton residences in
downtown l.a where they were staying
and what's your emergency my girlfriend
is not responding
are you with her right now yes the
singer was rushed to the hospital and
was later transferred to
another hospital facility in la to
receive mental health treatment from top
specialists
that was my lowest point of life
had you ever tried to take your life
before
i'm just gonna be a hundred percent um
there it's been a time where i wanted to
but this was the first time
you actually acted on it yeah
and while tamar wouldn't divulge the
details of that day
she says she's getting the help she
needs
i was diagnosed with depression and
anxiety due to a circumstance
are you medicating no i'm not medicated
but i am in counseling every single day
tamar also opens up about her family's
reality show
braxton family values tony called
and she told me that tamar was rushed
to the hospital because she tried to
commit suicide
this is not the show that i created i
created the braxton family of value
because i wanted to be
an example a part of the black community
with five black amazing
sisters with all different walks of life
who can inspire and help and people can
learn from our experiences along the way
the trailer for the latest season
dropped last week and in a since-deleted
instagram post
tamar weighed in calling it disgusting
adding quote and whomever else
participating for using my pain for
their pleasure and ratings
listen i'm not going to sit here and act
like a complete victim i played a part
in that
i think that
for the show and for my family we wanted
to have
a great show and sometimes that is
making the deal with the devil and it is
doing things
that you wouldn't normally do
you